Lost or need to replace your key fob?
You can program a new one yourself on
your 2017 GMC Sierra 1500, saving time
and money. This involves syncing the
fob's radio frequency with your truck's
receiver module. Note that as of late
2025, the process remains largely
unchanged from GM's original guidelines.
While aftermarket tools and apps can
assist, this video focuses on the manual
method using your truck's built-in
system. Keep in mind that the vehicle's
body control module, BCM, stores up to
four fobs. Programming overwrites old
ones. Battery depletion in key fobs
remains a common issue. Ensure you have
a fresh battery in your new fob before
starting.
First, ensure all doors are closed and
the key is out of the ignition.
Next, insert the key into the ignition.
Turn it to the on position, but don't
start the engine, then back to off.
Repeat this cycle three times within 10
seconds. The driver information center
may display remote learn pending.
Immediately, press and hold the lock and
unlock buttons on the new key fob
simultaneously for 15 seconds.
Finally, cycle the ignition again to the
on position and test the key fob. Repeat
steps two through four for any
additional fobs you want to program. If
the process fails, try again ensuring
precise timing or consider using an
aftermarket tool for assistance. If
issues persist, consult a professional
as aftermarket alarms or stereo systems
can interfere with the BCM signal.